so is it true that you've learned some
life skills from like some of your roles
this is what I love about actors they
come on here and you get to learn these
fun things because you have to play them
in the movies yeah like what what's
something you had to do well uh I
learned to lasso
I'm obsessed without a range but I can't
do that yeah well and taught me so
Brolin was like Yeah someone taught you
how to he knows about Alaska
that's cool well like right off the bat
yeah it did pretty well with lassoing
right off the bat the horseback riding
not so much oh no so you didn't wait
what do you mean did you fall off no I
wish I did I mean I feel like at a
certain point I think it would have been
less painful and embarrassing I've
fallen off a horse it hurts where did
you grow up at Texas okay so I grew up
in New Jersey so not a lot of horses
happening we're not really riding a lot
of horses sound like your room Texas
wow I love I love that you so you didn't
follow the horses did it buck with you
on it or something horse fly it was it
was the it was the trotting I was we
were on uh well I'm not a musician but I
guess downbeat wrong like a bad Rhythm
yeah you know the horse would go up and
I will come down the horse would go
oh no you gotta find that gate yeah it
was really painful it was really painful
yeah
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]